From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
La Biblioteca del Congreso le da
la bienvenida a personas de todo el
mundo para utilizar nuestras
salas de lectura para llevar a
cabo investigaciones.
Para acceder a nuestras
singulares colecciones ,
primero tendrá que obtener una
tarjeta de lector de la Biblioteca
del Congreso.
Esta tarjeta es gratuita y
disponible a cualquier persona mayor
de 16 años.
Debe presentar una tarjeta de lector
válida cada vez que entre a una
sala de lectura.
Si aún no tiene una tarjeta de de
lector o si su tarjeta ha expirado,
por favor vaya a la oficina
de Reader Registration.
La oficina de Reader Registration
está en el primer piso del edificio
James Madison, uno de los tres
edificios de la Biblioteca del
Congreso en Capitol Hill.
Después de pasar por seguridad,
gire a la izquierda y
proceda por el pasillo.
Encontrará la oficina
en la sala 140.
Necesitará presentar una
identificación vigente que tenga su
foto, como su licencia
de conducir, pasaporte,
o alguna otra identificación
emitida por el gobierno que muestre
su fecha de nacimiento.
Luego, le tomarán una fotografía,
firmará la tarjeta y su nueva
tarjeta de identificación de lector
será impresa inmediatamente.
Su tarjeta será valida por dos
años y puede ser renovada en la
oficina de Reader Registration.
Para acelerar el proceso
de registro,
usted puede pre-registrarse
en línea.
Sin embargo, necesitará presentarse
personalmente a la oficina de Reader
Registration para verificar su
identificación y para obtener
su tarjeta.
La oficina de Reader Registration
está abierta de lunes a sábado.
Antes de su visita, por favor visite
nuestra página web para ver las
horas de servicio al público.
Para cualquier pregunta o duda sobre
el proceso de registración o si
necesita registrar un
grupo muy numeroso,
por favor comuníquese de
antemano con la oficina de Reader
Registration llamando
al 202-707-5278.
Una vez que tenga su
tarjeta de lector,
puede proceder a cualquiera de las
salas de lectura en la biblioteca y
usar las colecciones.
Algunas salas de lectura tienen
requisitos especiales sobre cómo
usar sus colecciones.
Por ejemplo, los investigadores que
deseen utilizar la sala de Libros
Raros y Colecciones Especiales
tienen que ser mayores de 18 años.
Para más información sobre los
requisitos para usar algunas salas,
por favor visite nuestra página
web en loc.gov/rr Y recuerde,
la biblioteca nacional
es su biblioteca.
Esperamos verlos muy pronto.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as loc.gov.